ce soir un million et demi de foyers
sont toujours privés d'électricité selon
edf qui demande de ne pas toucher aux
lignes électriques tombés au sol
fait exceptionnel le plan orsec a été
déclenché dans quatre départements les
vosges la marne la haute-marne et la
meurthe et moselle
reportage dans l'est de la france avec
nos correspondants à strasbourg jérôme
soûlard et patrice thomas cher des
rafales à 160 kilomètres/heure avec une
telle force les toitures se soulève
comme des feuilles les antennes vacille
et les routes deviennent vite
impraticable dans cette tornade
deux personnes vont trouver la mort lui
noyer l'autre écrasé par la chute d'un
arbre sur sa voiture au nord de
strasbourg
la forêt de brumath et en partie dévasté
les axes de circulation sont presque
totalement bloqués c'est d'ailleurs le
premier travail des pompiers
établir la sécurité sur les principaux
axes de communication ce qui fut en
priorité chez nous c'était donc que
dégageaient les la chaussée quand nous
sommes en train de faire maintenant
et puis éviter qui a d'autres dans qt
d'arbres sur éventuellement des voitures
qui passent à quelques kilomètres de là
ce sont des pylônes tdf que le vent a
brisé tel de simples château de cartes
les lignes à haute tension sont tombés
sur l'autoroute de paris des centaines
d'automobilistes étaient encore bloqués
en fin d'après midi
on a vu les arbres tombés sur les
voitures alors on fait dire par rentrer
ça fait plus de deux heures de trois
heures de notre local ici trois heures
c'est pas fini pas à pas l'air de bouger
beaucoup plus de routes et plus de train
non plus depuis ce matin l'ensemble du
réseau sncf est complètement paralysée
pour les arrivées tout est bloqué aucun
train depuis 9h ce matin ne rentre il ne
peut quitter la gare de strasbourg
conséquence les voyageurs bloqués
devront être relogées dans des wagons
couchettes car les prévisions météo
restent pessimistes
nous restons très vigilants pour la
soirée car
mais la météo nous annonce une reprise
du vent autour de 100 kilomètres heure
pour la fin de soirée
en alsace les dégâts de cette tempête
est ce soir très important cent vingt
mille foyers sont d'ailleurs toujours
privés d'électricité et en bretagne